Hey so just a disclaimer I went through
the physics system in Australia and New
Zealand so some of the details about
course structures are going to be a
little bit different especially if
you're in the US where grad school can
take a long time the most basic
difference between undergrad physics and
post-grad physics is the fact that when
you're an undergrad you're doing courses
and exams and you're attending lectures
you're in taking information processing
it and then regurgitating it through an
exam in sort of a every semester cycle
the big difference about postgraduate
physics is that it's a lot more
research-based I did a few sort of
graduate level physics courses and
what's called my honours year and that's
sort of a uniquely kind of Australian
thing but it means that now in my ph.d
program I am only doing research so this
is essentially three years of research
on one topic of physics I've got a
supervisor and a research group I no
longer have any exams and everything
that I'm doing is sort of guided by
fundamental research questions the
experiments that I do any calculations
or maths that I do is is based around
finding out new things things that
haven't been discovered before and that
makes it so much more exciting than
undergrad physics at least for me
because I feel like I'm finally
contributing to physics rather than just
spending my time learning things that
are already known and whilst that's
important there's kind of a futility
about it that can make you feel a bit
down for that reason I prefer post-grad
physics so much more than undergrad but
it doesn't really work like that for
everyone and getting high grades and
undergrad physics doesn't necessarily
mean you're going to be
a great researcher or great at post-grad
for post-grad you're really training to
become a scientist in the academic sense
you're reading papers trying to find out
what you think's interesting and finding
creative ways to pursue it the qualities
you need to become a good scientist in
this sense are things like creativity
determination and a lot of patience some
of the experiments especially and an
even theoretical work can require many
days and hours of effort before you see
any kind of result undergrad is more of
an instant gratification type thing
because you can hand in an assignment
get a good grade and feel good about
yourself feel that your efforts have
been validated people who got really
high grades and undergrad might be good
at memorizing information rote learning
things or just sort of knowing what to
say
in exam conditions and those skills
aren't at all really useful in post-grad
an undergrad as well what you do kind of
just affects you you can slack off all
semester and then cram for an exam and
while that's not a great tactic if you
can do it and get away with it it kind
of doesn't matter it's just affecting
your grade but as a post grad you've got
obligations and responsibilities to your
supervisor to any collaborators to your
research group you're sort of actually
working on something so there's a lot
more expected of you in terms of
contributing to others I can comment on
what the major differences between
classic undergrad courses and more
advanced work it's kind of what you
would expect you're going more deep into
the same subjects that you learnt as
undergrad so for an example take
electromagnetism this is something that
you probably studied in school and
studied in almost every semester or
definitely every year of uni you would
have had some iteration of an
electromechanical eight the magnetic
field around the wire an array of
charges but you've got quite simple
geometry as a graduate you will almost
certainly be using this horrendous beast
which is Jackson's electrodynamics
and it just goes a lot more in-depth
into things designed so that the
problems that you work on it's maybe one
problem from Jackson it's going to take
you hours and hours and in an exam you
might just have two or three questions
from Jackson and that would be your
whole exam where as an undergrad you
might have like I don't know ten fifteen
questions from a more basic form of
electromagnet ins you should be pretty
much at the top of whatever respective
field you've chosen to study as you go
on through the years of studying physics
the questions you do a less sort of
cookie cutter and more involved they
they no longer fit into one nice section
of physics but they may stretch over a
range of different physics areas as well
as a range of different mathematical
techniques you need to solve them and I
think that's reflective of what problems
are really like if you become a
scientist
it's very rare that you're going to find
something that you can solve with only
knowledge one area of physics you need
to be thinking really broadly and
graduate school is going to help make
you that broad thinker